[Music]  [Applause]  um  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  foreign  [Music]  long considered the caviar of the east  bird's nest or more specifically the  dried saliva of swiftlet birds is a rare  treat  these birds prefer to build their nests  in dark caves and in the philippines  nest gatherers go to great heights  literally to collect them  on  [Music]  [Music]  the work may be dangerous but these nest  gatherers are willing to risk their  lives because the payoff is worth it  is  [Music]  is  traditionally the role of a nest  gatherer is passed down from generation  to generation so while this may seem  frightening for angelito it's an honor  [Music]  um  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  you